now andy i have something very
important to talk about here at the top
of the show okay before jay farrell
comes out
i think you know what i'm talking about
ladies and gentlemen
this is crucially important there is a
song
that's trending right now on tick-tock
that caught my attention now it's a song
that normally probably wouldn't have
caught my attention
but uh it's by star boy featuring doja
cat
not that i don't love those two when
they work together but
it's not really my thing uh and they
they put a song out
that's doing quite well right now and
it's entitled dick
yes and no it's not about the great
actor richard harris
[Laughter]
or nixon or it's not about nixon it's
about
as some of you can probably guess a
penis
dick slang for penis aka
dick dick penis penis dick dick is penis
and
penis of course [ __ ] but also dick now
the reason i bring all this up is
because
um well the song is absolutely filthy
okay but i want to read you a very
important part of the lyrics it goes
dick dick dick dick as you would expect
uh i'm going in tonight uh
she acting like an addict
thicker than andy richter
that's a lyric in the song you're you're
you're you're called out by name finally
impacting the culture yes finally well
tell us first of all how do you feel
about being name checked in the song
dick i mean it i am kind of you know
it's fun to be
name checked but i wish that in the
in the song dick that i weren't being
name-checked
to refer to the voluptuousness of a
woman
which is essentially what they're saying
they're saying that the woman who's
lining up
for the or you know who's anticipating
yeah she's
she's thicker than andy richter no i
thought the dick was thicker than andy
rick no no
wait a minute no no no hold on a second
first of all
what that would
here's what i took it to be and this is
you should be proud of this
that a uh a penis with
girth is is an andy richter that's how i
think of it
see i thought she was saying she's an
addict meaning she's addicted
to dick and that and then
to further describe her she's thicker
than andy richter
no no no no no no no i have studied this
text
okay quite quite seriously and i've
consulted with
friends uh who've also spent a lot of
time uh studying
literature then [ __ ] just got a cause
i took the gym give him a job and he
gave me a rim
gave her uh something for the tires on
his car
it was too long so he gave me a min i
think that's a minute of your time
how's that possible give me a kim no
idea what's going on there i can't
describe it just give me a pen and why
he in your tummy but
winding my wrist well that's open to a
lot of interpretation
but i think she acted like an addict
thicker than andy richter
i met the boy in the six but
measurements was in the six
i like the side of the pickle i just got
morty and ricked
uh and please let me stress all of this
sounds better coming from doji cat
yes this is her milieu it is not mine
but i heard this song and i thought hey
wait a minute if it gets out there in
the culture
that someone with a
large unit so to speak is thicker than
andy richter
you're you win you win big time
no one's going to ever say whip out that
conan let's see what you got
you know no one's ever going to say he
owned me long into the night
all right i i can't ride a horse today
because i was conan
all night that's not gonna happen right
right none of that's happening
you you don't get it this is huge for
you
i'm now synonymous with chode
yes but just listen to some of the song
we're gonna play it right now with all
the beeps beeped out
with all the except the crucial part
check it out
[Music]
i'm going in tonight
[Music]
you know what i've never been happier
for you